imagine avec quoi hein et crochus
vieille laide et méchante et non et non
pourtant sophie est bel et bien une
sorcière elle peut s'immiscer dans le
monde des morts est entré en contact
avec des esprits
pour moi ce ne sont que des ressentis un
expliqué dans une pièce je ne vais pas
le voir comme certaines personnes
les voyants qu'ils les voient vraiment
comme si c'était une très une personne
moi pas du tout pour moi c'est une ombre
mais par contre je vais savoir à peu
près son âge fait savoir s'il avait vu
où elle est jeune si c'est un homme ou
une femme si elle est méchante ou pas
des rencontres avec l'au delà qui dure
depuis plusieurs années intimement liées
à sa pratique du oui kahnisme une
religion une croyance inspiré du
paganisme on voit un culte à la nature
on croit en un dieu qui est omniprésent
qui détient la vérité qui est la vérité
qui est amour qui qui est la conscience
universelle
il a sa partie masculine
c'est le lieu sert une hausse la partie
féminine de la déesse lunaire un dieu
presque présent lors des sortilèges à
l'envoyé de la bougie verte avant grâce
à la lame à la déesse l'a fait pour
l'esprit c'est la lumière divine et l'a
fait la bougie rouge qui symbolise sur
une hausse le dieu une ambiance mystique
propice à la sorcellerie que sophie a
réussi à apprivoiser pour moi c'est
tellement normal maintenant c'est normal
avant j'en aurai pas parlé mais non je
puis je suis bien dans mon monde de
sorcières je suis à l'aise je peux en
parler ouvertement maintenant je mon mât
rassuré sur mon état mental
donc tout va mener à une vie de dogmes
et d'incantations oui mais elle le dit
un quotidien bien terre à terre parfois
cartésien
même un peu trop normal pour une
sorcière